foreign
[Music]
Welcome to our talk run your high
performance database workloads on any
cloud with ledb or what I wanted to call
it what is ledb why is it cool why
should I care
um if this isn't the talk that you
thought it was hang around anyway it
will hopefully be at least mildly
entertaining and we'll tell you about
some really cool database product that
we've got coming up Ali DB which as of
today
yesterday yesterday from Tech preview
over to public preview so it's even more
available to play with who are we
um I am Gabe Weiss I am a developer
advocate for Google Cloud specializing
in database and infrastructure and my
two friends on stage Kevin I'm Kevin
Jernigan I lead the product team for
Ally to be Omni
and I'm Simon Payne I'm a consultant
from a company called pythian and we
help customers with all sorts of cloud
and database needs so now you know who
we are
who are you well so for today our agenda
this is what I wanted to do because I
like doing demos that's why I'm here and
that's why Simon's here we brought him
on stage to do the demos and then they
said no you probably need to actually
talk about the product a little bit so
instead this is what we're gonna do
um we're we've moved through the
introduction phase we're going to do a
little bit of what is alodb our Cloud
version so you can kind of wrap your
head around the product in general and
why the downloadable version is cool we
all go into talking about the
downloadable version lodb Omni we'll
walk through a couple of use cases we'll
do some demos live Demos in here
um with the Moscone internet we'll see
how it goes we'll pray to the demo Gods
um then we're going to skip the next
part and then I will wrap up
so now that we have covered that I would
like to know who you all are
um first I like to kind of get a pulse
from the audience how many of you
consider yourselves like application
developers software Engineers people
Hands-On keyboard
nice you're my people I love you all
thank you for being here do we have any
dbas
I'm seeing some in the same hands cool
uh what about like it decision makers
the people that decided on your stack
you know
are do you all do everything so startups
how many are from startups
some of the same hands yep good okay uh
how about embedded system designers
I see one kinda all right this is
probably not the right talk but stick
around anyway because we'll keep you
entertained so what actually is omnidb
it's a product did you know that
Google's actually shipping a product
it's not a service
we usually work in services in the cloud
right all of our standard applications
we've got VMS we've got serverless all
of those are things that we're running
now we're shipping a product something
that you all run I'll be ledb Omni is a
proper product it's got release notes
and like the readme in the package when
you download it it's cool so there's a
lot of differences between like what is
a product versus a service and I kind of
touched on it a service is something
that we run we take care of it we manage
it we cover the SLA we cover maintenance
if it goes down we're the ones that are
on the hook for it product you all get
to run
there's some good and the bad in there
obviously like you know we're covering
all of the the management of the thing
but that also means that we restrict it
in certain ways so one of the nice
things about a product is you all get to
own it you get to do what you need to it
so if you need it working on premises
cool run it on premises if you've got
very specific requirements around
containment air gapping we now have a
product that you can do that with with
all the power of ledb
so what is ledb
to understand the product that we've
launched I want to just really quick did
how many of you actually went to the
alodb session that was up yesterday or
the main session from yesterday
it looks like about half of you okay so
I'll cover some stuff anyway but they
went into way more detail about Ollie DB
than I'm going to I'm going to touch on
a lot of the points that I really care
about and then I feel strongly about
about it from the development from the
kind of user standpoint of what's
important to me so I'll ADB itself just
so that we get the Baseline out of the
way it is a postgres compatible database
and not just a database engine it has a
lot of stuff around it it covers things
like the ability to spin up read pools
for you all the manageability around
that it's got a lot of extra Magic on
top of postgres that we've built into it
around things like performance around
um
yeah all that good stuff so all of the
management that you get from a Google
cloud service things like automated
backups all the data encryption in
transit at rest all of that stuff Google
Cloud hands will for you uh curated list
of extensions like I said part of having
a service means that we restrict things
a little bit so on extensions everyone
loves post postgres extensions that's
kind of what we live and breathe on if
we use postgres
certain extensions do potentially really
awful things for your database with a
managed service we can't let you have
that full freedom because we are
beholden to an SLA to make sure that
it's available so there are certain
extensions that we hold back because we
know that the likelihood of it
destabilizing your databases there so
the cloud alloy DB we don't let you have
all of those extensions so having said
that I want to walk through a couple of
what I consider the real highlights of
audio DB for me first up is performance
idb is four times faster than postgres
out of the box
for certain kinds of analytical queries
it's up to 100 times x so how did we
actually do that first we control
end-to-end Hardware we can specialize
the software specifically and optimize
for the hardware that we've got there
are certain other companies that do the
same thing like they don't let you put
your stuff on other Hardware Apple so
they are and we are able to optimize
performance specifically for the
hardware that we know we've got so we
can make software changes to take
advantage of that
the columnar engine is the core part of
where the performance comes for these
analytical queries we have a separate
caching system that we've added to
postgres that instead of storing as like
the buffer cache does in a row format
changes into columnar format that
optimizes certain types of queries so if
you're doing aggregate queries give me
everything you know with a couple of
predicates where my price is over a
hundred dollars and I only want
um Tuesdays you know any of those kinds
of queries a columnar format optimizes
for those kinds so you can do analytical
queries in loudb faster and more
efficiently than you can on out of the
box postgres
then we've got real-time business
insights who knows what real-time
business insights actually means
me neither
I got a couple of sales yeah there you
go so uh I stole some of these from our
sales guys real-time business insights
to me means two different things if you
ask a sales guy they're gonna say that
this is because you can actually what I
was talking about these analytical
queries I want to get information out of
my data that's real-time business
Insight I think of it more of I want to
see what is going on with my database I
don't want to have to set up a bunch of
like I.T folks staring at a screens
checking my CPU utilization is this
query like
um out of control what's going on
part of the advantage of a managed
system is within our console you have
those tools built in so I know what the
CPU utilization is of my audio DB
instances by going to the cloud console
and I can see it for me that's like
real-time business insights is knowing
what's up with my database without me
having to build that plumbing so that's
that one slas is another advantage of
having a managed service we guarantee
that it's up
ODB guarantees 99.99 four nines
availability that's like what 20 minutes
of downtime a month I think is that what
that one works out too I forgot the math
something less I think it's something
four four minutes a month thank you so
four minutes a month is it now something
with lodb that is new to that database
compared to other slas that includes
maintenance so anytime that we need to
take your instances down to do updates
to do cleaning on the data whatever
stability stuff we need to do that
includes that so four minutes a month
counting any of that downtime that we
need to do for maintenance
ml driven management and configuration
so iodb includes some cool machine
learning now we're not talking about
like the duet AI stuff that you've been
hearing all over the conference this is
this happened before the the mad rush on
this ml driven management configuration
is things like with postgres one of the
biggest hits that can happen to your
database is when do you clean it when
you do that vacuuming when you delete
actually delete the data that you've
marked for delete
one of the cool things about alodb we've
included is this vacuum management where
we will figure out based on your
workload pattern based on your like when
the intense workloads are coming in when
to do that cleanup for you you don't
have to manage it anymore we can do that
for you so we figure out the best time
to do it so it doesn't impact we have
storage and memory disaggregation so
your compute your processing and the
storage itself are separate in ledb so
both of them scale independently so we
can help manage the optimal use of
either storage or your memory to make
sure that we are getting the best bang
for your buck out of your instance and
then last we've got data tiering does
anyone know what data tiering means
so data tiering is putting the data
based on your usage so into the fastest
part of your either memory storage Cold
Storage so we arrange the most used data
in the place where it's going to be
accessed the fastest so we have the part
of the machine learning is to figure out
which data goes where so that's what
that one is then we've got transparent
particular pricing again remember I
stole these for most of our sales guys
this means that we are very clear about
where the pricing comes from we don't
have any hidden charges the price is
what the price is you've got your
Ingress and egress charging so if you
can figure out how much data you've got
where it's moving to and how much
processing power you need it's very
clear how much this is going to cost
it's not going to like surprise you with
hidden charges anywhere so that's what
that one is
so having said that now we have a handle
on the manage version of lodb
take all of that
stick it in a couple of containers and
now you can deploy it anywhere I think
of ledb kind of like the um the where's
Waldo of cloud databases you can kind of
find it anywhere but you don't really
know where to find it because it's not
connected to the cloud when you do it of
course not I probably lost you all
because you're all looking for a while
though aren't you let me help
foreign
I've got I've got more if you really
want to do where's Waldo we can do more
of those later so now I would like to
hand it off to Kevin to go into a little
more detail about all ADB on me
thanks Gabe um
this is supposed to be a container by
the way on this slide and uh ledb lives
inside a container when you download it
you're actually downloading a Docker
container with the ldb engine in it we
actually have a little component in a
separate container that manages the
memory but basically you're downloading
a Docker container so this is how it
comes but then the question is what
environments does it run on and so you
know we support
there we go we support a whole bunch of
environments
um certain flavors of Linux Red Hat
Ubuntu Debian
and then we also support
um running in various clouds not just on
premises not just in a server that you
manage you can also run it obviously in
Google cloud in your own GCE instance
you can write an AWS you're going to see
some live action on AWS in a minute you
can run it in Azure you can run it in
any probably pretty much any Cloud your
private Cloud your data center
you can run on a laptop
so and we will have a demo on the laptop
in a little bit too so it only really
needs a two gig of memory two CPUs and
20 gig of storage to get started so if
you have a laptop with that much
capabilities you can run it there or you
know pick a server running in a cloud
environment for that
so it runs anywhere packaged in a
downloadable container
and and again you can put it almost
anywhere but it has all the same
capabilities that you just heard about
in alodb cloud with a couple exceptions
because ldb Omni does not have the
separation of compute and storage so you
don't get the benefits of that the extra
performance and other capabilities of
separating compute and storage and of
course it doesn't have a control plane
it's managed by you it's not managed by
us so you know you'll have to figure out
and I'll talk about this more in a
minute you'll have to figure out how to
set up AJ and backup some replication
we're going to give you a bunch of help
on how to do that
um having said that it still scales
really high it scales much better than
stock postgres because a lot of the
improvements we made in ledb were to the
core postgres engine for high
concurrency scalable workloads on larger
servers with lots of CPUs ledbi Omni
still scales really well it scales about
half as high as ldb in the cloud
and it's got a bunch of intelligence
built in like I talked about like like
Gabe talked about to manage things like
vacuum and memory and other things so up
to two times the throughput of stock
postgres we see that result those
performance results in transactional
benchmarks so we see these kinds of
results when you have high concurrency
and small transactions which is typical
of a lot of workloads and I actually set
up to two it's actually more than 2x the
bigger the machine the more CPUs the
further it pulls away from stock
postgres because stock post grows flat
lines at somewhere between 12 and 16
CPUs
you can give it 32 or 64. it won't go
faster so we're actually more than 2X
and ledb cloud is more than 4X at the
high end
oops went the wrong way
there there we go
um there it is again yeah allowed to be
omnic includes the columnar engine it
works exactly the same way as it does in
the clouds it's the same code same
capabilities gives you up to 100x
performance improvements or more and
depends on the query and the data and
all that
um but that's all exactly the same as it
runs on the cloud because the columnar
engine doesn't depend on separation of
compute and storage you get a bunch of
stuff in the special columnar format in
memory and then the queries will run
much faster so if you have the same CPU
same amount of memory same data same
queries they'll run exactly they'll get
the same performance improvements
whether it's LED cloud or LGB Omni
and it has all the same ml driven
management built in
adaptive vacuum management adaptive
memory management
it also will automatically move data
into the columnar format based upon your
query patterns your workload pattern and
it will also we also have the index
advisor so it will actually watch your
query patterns look at your data and
suggest indexes that you might want to
add or take away from your tables
there
um
we're not going to talk much about
pricing today we are planning to
announce pricing soon the focus is going
to be very similar to what you see with
ledb in the cloud make it transparent
predictable easy to understand and
affordable when we launched originally
back in late March we made a commitment
that our pricing would be a fraction of
the cost of Legacy databases and that's
not going to change when we actually
announce the pricing you'll you'll see
where that fits
so this slide is a good comparison of
allodb in the cloud the left most column
ldb Omni and self-managed postgres so
I'm not going to go through everything
on this slide but you can see the
performance differences in terms of
throughput differences the 4X and 2x
should actually be more than 4X and more
than 2X
the analytics performance is the same
for both alliedb versions because it's
the same columnar engine capability
they both have the autopilot
capabilities all the ml driven automatic
management
um and SLA is kind of important to
understand as Gabe pointed out this is a
product that you manage so it's not a
service that we can give you an SLA for
so I'm going to talk a little bit about
how we're helping you with that and
we're going to give you more help over
time but it's still a product that
you're going to install and manage in
your infrastructure
um
and the same thing for the backups and
replication Etc we're going to help you
in setting all that up but it's still
your job to actually set up and monitor
and manage your backups and replication
in your ha and Dr setups
and then finally support we will be
providing standard Google support all
the way up to Google premium support
depending upon what level you've signed
up for for your ally DB installations
um it's obviously going to be a bit
different since we're not in you know
you're not running in our infrastructure
where you can see things happening so
it's going to be a different support
experience only because you'll have to
reach out to us and give us information
on your your environments and all that
but we are going to provide the same
level of Support over time as we do for
our on-prem for our sorry for our
cloud-based services
all right
I went the wrong way again
down is up yes down is Up Up Is Down so
let's talk about common use cases and so
the first use case that we've heard from
customers because you might be wondering
why do we do Omni in the first place
you know we have this great cloud
service why are we doing this thing that
isn't in the cloud
um and really the the first use case is
customers who have a big Fleet of Legacy
databases on-premises you know 5000
Oracle databases 10 000 SQL Server
databases they want to move off of those
databases but they're not ready to move
to the cloud so they can't get to the
goodness of ledb in the cloud
but they want to move off and they're
not ready to get to the Cloud so we're
trying to give them basically an
Enterprise grade postgres with
Enterprise grade support and that's
really where Alibi Omni fits is in that
space where customers have workloads
that aren't ready for the cloud but are
ready for a higher end postgres so I'm
going to hand it off to Simon because
he's going to do his our first demo of
the day all right thanks Kevin and can
we switch please at the back to the demo
computer so I get all the excitement
here because I'm going to do some live
demos and I'm actually doing them all
live I'm going to do some in Google
Cloud here and then later in AWS
so I'm actually going to just open up
this is my own personal Google Cloud
account on
you guys can turn to each other now and
make bets as to whether the uh yamos are
going to fail or not I like to live on
the edge with live demos and I'm
actually going to paste in a command
really quickly to start it off because
it takes two minutes to run and then I'm
going to explain
with what exactly is happening in my
command so here's my command I'm going
to try to copy it I'm going to try and
paste it here into my cloud shell
if you first thing went it worked oh
close to working and there we go
so what am I doing here well
what I'm doing is a really quick start
to get alloy DB Omni up and running so I
first started it about using it about
six months ago when did the first
preview come out March 29th March 29th
okay and even season DBA sometimes are a
little bit confused about the whole
container aspect on running in Docker
containers and really what I want to
emphasize is it's really simple to get
started the reason I wanted to paste the
command here is because it takes about
two minutes and to end and I think
that's pretty impressive that we're
going to go from nothing oh that wasn't
two minutes well that's only because all
we did is so far is provision Some Cloud
infrastructure so if we hit refresh what
I did here is I just used a Google Cloud
API command the gcloud command to
provision a virtual machine and you
don't have to do this in Google Cloud
you could do this on premises using
VMware I do it using Kickstart files and
things like that I just provisioned some
very simple infrastructure and then I
just went to the alloy DB quick start
documentation here and you can go here
and there's some very simple steps so if
anybody in your organization or you
personally are not very familiar with
Docker and containers and it adds a
little bit of a level of fear
uncertainty and doubt it's very easy to
get past that all I've done is really
take all these very simple commands I
copied and pasted them into a startup
script and really that's what I did in
my command over here
let me just switch back
the other tab is really all I did is
created a new VM and I passed into there
a name of a startup script and it was
running so yes as Gabe pointed out the
machine coming up happened very quickly
because Google Provisions the
infrastructure very quickly and now I
can connect to it and what's happening
in the background is all I did was cut
and paste
those commands as I said into a startup
script and it's going to install Docker
for me download the container and really
get everything up and ready to go
so now we just wait a little bit as we
connect to the terminal and this is a
nice part about Google Cloud by the way
the fact that you don't have to have a
terminal client you could just ssh in
directly from the cloud console
and how long has it been has it been two
minutes oh let's find out oh yep it has
been it's all done so what I see here is
that it's downloaded and it's got an
installation directory it's called a
data directory it's also created and
it's done and I actually augmented the
instructions a little bit to build
myself my own little readme file and if
I take a look at my readme I give myself
some quick notes of how I can connect
and I can just highlight that and paste
and there we go
ta-da I mean to
Omni already so that was less than uh a
couple minutes and I went from zero to
having everything provisioned and again
I'd like to emphasize you don't have to
do this in Cloud Google Cloud using
gcloud commands there's lots of other
ways where you can do something very
similar to spin it up really quickly for
your devs
and each iteration this is getting
easier and easier to do so like the tech
preview was a little funky you had to
run the docker commands to get the the
stuff this is now the next level these
instructions include with it now a
command line tool that lets you just do
server install and it does it and it'll
keep getting easier as we iterate so on
that I'll turn it back over to you until
later on yeah and yeah like Gabe was
saying one of the things we launched
yesterday is a CLI do you want to switch
please yeah we switch back to the slides
thanks
um so that now there's a CLI to make
everything that that Simon just showed
you even easier
um because he had to type in a lot of
stuff into scripts and now you can just
use the CLI commands and it's a lot less
less effort and less complexity and
that's all documented in the doc the doc
update we dropped yesterday
um so what's our next use case well it's
on the edge and what do we really mean
by Edge this is kind of a bunch of sub
use cases here so for example telcos
telcos need to have databases very very
close to their customers in a lot of
cases they install racks and closets and
on customer on company premises because
they need real low latency for the users
using those databases they've been doing
this for years
and they've been doing it with Legacy
expensive databases and they want to
move to an Enterprise postgres with
Enterprise support
um so Alabama is a really good fit for
that use case now the use case is what
we Loosely call retail Edge
so there's lots of retailers out there
with lots of stores and they've been
running databases in their stores for
years for similar reasons they need the
stores to keep running even when they
lose connectivity to the Internet so
they all run local databases everywhere
they're never going to move those to the
cloud because they just need to stay up
and running even when there's a flood
and they lose connectivity but still
have a local generator to keep the power
on in the store that's an example that
we've been given several times
and other other examples that aren't
even on the slide that that came up more
recently manufacturing on the factory
floor they run databases on the floor
because they can't afford to have the
assembly line stop when they lose
connectivity so there's a lot of use
cases like that where customers want
a database that runs locally truly
locally they can't they cannot move
those to the cloud
and so I'm going to hand it off to Gabe
now for another demo back to the demo
laptop please so the business use cases
on the edge are great
but what if I just want to use it on the
edge or what if I'm at Moscone yesterday
and my internet goes completely kaput
and and what if you're I would like to
continue using a database and what if
you're a developer who just yeah so I I
will what I would like to show you now
is um I have I'll make sure it's still
kind of going here
um
on my laptop in a virtual environment I
have installed alloy DB Omni similarly
to what Simon had showed us all the
steps so now I have it running locally
um so I want to show you real quick that
I have the 192 so you know that this is
local
and I would not create all these tables
of my own volition so you know this is
ledb Omni because it has all of the all
of the the tables built for you so this
is now running locally on my laptop and
I have a little script here that is I
call it the faker script it generates a
a fake data set of
um employees at a company so just to
show you like right now I've got 13 14
rows 13 18 so the script that I just
fired is currently adding rows to my my
database so what I'm going to do now I'm
going to make sure I'm going to pull the
correct thing
I'm going to disconnect my internet
I have just pulled the cable off the
cord and to show you if I try and go
somewhere I have no internet but you'll
notice I'm still running against the
database
and if I can get back to it
it's still adding rows to my database
so there's nothing connected about ledb
Omni it's running completely locally
there's no internet it's only on my
laptop
so no matter where you are even if you
become disconnected you can run against
aloe to be on me
slides please and hand it back to Kevin
yeah and just one point on that yeah
there's no connectivity there's no phone
home built into Alibi Omni today we do
plan to add capabilities over time that
will make it useful for you to connect
to back to Google cloud in fact in the
public preview we've already added
support for connecting your ldb instant
ldb Omni instance with vertex AI so you
can actually connect it back into the
cloud and use vertex for inference and
other fun stuff can we switch back to
the slides please
all right so the third use case we want
to talk about
is multi-cloud got lots of customers
have lots of workloads running in
multiple clouds they either built
different application Stacks in
different clouds because they needed
certain special capabilities only
available in that cloud or they acquired
companies over time with different
stacks and different clouds and they
want a common database running in all
these clouds and they want to Common
database that has the capabilities that
ldb Omni has and so they can have you
know one standard way to support all of
these workloads and so Omni runs the
same way on all these different clouds
it's the same code it's the same
postgres compatibility it's the same
columnar engine it's the same
scalability it's the same autopilot
capabilities the same everywhere and so
that's been really appealing to a lot of
customers we've talked to and so now
Simon's going to give us another fun
demo yeah he needs to run through some
slides did you notice my colleague
almost sabotaged me there because he
forgot to plug the internet back in I
know it works well without internet uh
not the AWS demo part fair enough right
so it doesn't work without internet so
luckily I caught that so as partners
we're asked to do all sorts of things
like moves migrations to the cloud and
understanding how customers helping
customers understand how they can
leverage new features or increase
performance so what I wanted to do now
is set up a more complicated and
interesting demo where I'm going to
simulate running alloy DB Omni and
Aurora in AWS
so what I want to show is that really
this is easy okay we don't need to do
anything special we can install Omni
right into an ec2 instance in AWS just
like I did in Google Cloud on a virtual
machine there and the reason we might
want to do this is to test some of the
unique features that loadb brings so
this is a diagram I drew which I think
will help everybody understand what I'm
about to do when I go to the terminal
screen so really my architecture is this
I have one ec2 instance and I'm about to
terminal into it if the internet came
back after that Dave's demo there
yesterday that's good you tested it okay
because if the internet came doesn't
come back it's not going to be a very
good demo so I'm going to tell I'm going
to terminal into that one ec2 instance
where alloy DB omni's already running
that's my local database and then I'm
going to also connect to an Amazon
Aurora which I created earlier and I'm
going to actually simulate some data
coming across and testing some of the
new features of alloy DB Omni so I'm
trying to make a very realistic use case
and I didn't want to use is just the
standard PG bench data which is very
artificial and everybody knows and maybe
some people like so another colleague at
a totally different presentation used
this thing called the Chicago data
portal because he was from Chicago I'm
not
um but I love Chicago I was just in
Chicago and it's a it's a fantastic City
but it they expose very large data set
all sorts of different things and what I
did to prepare this demo is I just look
for business licenses and I've
downloaded the business licenses table
and I downloaded it the other day it's
constantly being updated and I put it
into my Aurora database and the use case
I'm trying to simulate here is maybe
somebody's opening a new business and
they want to run a query to say what
other how many other new businesses
opened in the last 90 days in my ZIP
code now sure that's not a necessarily
an analytic query but still I'm going to
turn on the columnar engine afterwards
and we can see some of the advantages so
can we switch to the demo computer now
please
all right so let's see if the internet
truly is back otherwise it won't be too
much of a demo all right it's back so as
you can see
this green prompt is that ec2 Amazon
database that I showed in the
illustration a second ago and what I can
do here is I can connect and I'll first
show that I have
Omni installed locally so whenever I
connect and I use localhost
I've connected I've pre-created a
database called Chicago because that's
where my table is going to be in the
Chicago data set now Gabe showed us all
the tables there and he said he didn't
you know somebody's not going to emulate
having all those tables or views and
things like that to uh
convince you that we're really running
against Omni I'm a little bit more
trusting so I would usually when I
connect just look at what users exist
and I can see there's an alloy DB admin
user and a replica user or I can look at
what default databases exist and we can
see again we got alloy DB admin so
hopefully from that that's good proof
that whenever I connect and I use
localhost I'm connecting to Omni now the
other thing too as I said is I have an
aurora instance now AWS gives you very
big long endpoint names so to make
things a little bit simpler for myself I
just put that in a variable yeah so
there there's the
Aurora endpoint but I can connect to it
by just using this variable so let's
just test that make sure that works as
well
Aurora
and again I'll use the same techniques
if I look here and I look at the users I
can see I have RDS admin and replication
and so forth or I can look at the
databases and I can see that there's an
RDS one
so hopefully I convinced you that
whenever I connect with the Aurora I'm
connecting with the dollar sign Aurora
variable I'm connecting to the Aurora
instance and when I connect as localhost
I'm not I'm connecting to Omni so let's
just go into my scripts directory here
and the first thing I want to show is I
loaded this table and I loaded it in uh
the 11 million or so rows and let's just
do a quick query on the Aurora site and
see how many rows are actually there
should have given a variable that was a
little bit easier to type like just
dollar a maybe
there we go okay so we have a nice easy
number to remember there's three ones
and it ends with 88. that's how many are
on the Aurora side now let's see have I
created my table even on the alloy DB
side or just the database well we can
just change this connect to the Omni
side and take a look nope the table
doesn't exist so what I have running in
Aurora is I have logical replication
through PG logical and if you don't know
uh postgres replication that's all right
that's not really necessary for this
demo just understand that postgres can
provide logical replication in near real
time to any number of targets so in this
case I've pre-configured that on the
Aurora database now to start the
replication I need to actually create
the empty table here on the
alloy DB Omni side so let's just do that
let's just create the table
voila and now let's just test again the
table exists and has zero rows so all I
have to do to start copying
through replication some of my live data
that might be in my AWS Aurora into my
lodb Omni because I want to experiment
there is just create a PG logical
subscription so first of all I might
want to just test in Aurora and make
sure my table has been added to my
replication set that's just the list of
what tables are going to be replicating
and of course in a real use case you're
going to have tons of different tables
but for me I just have this one business
licenses that I downloaded and all I'm
going to do is simply add it to
a subscription on the Omni side
so let's do that
we'll just say
great subscription and this is a good
time to bet with your neighbor if demos
are going to fail or not
okay so we created a subscription and
now let's just see if the rows came
across
might take a second or two so we do
account right now and it's zero so now
everybody hold your breath if I do it
again is the data there nope not looking
good for the demos oh a few there we go
a little a little bit worried there that
it took a second and is it replicating
just once or is it doing it in real time
well we can go and we can add a row back
so actually let's just connect in in
psql and manually add a row so if I just
describe
business
licenses again I should have picked a
table it was easier to type I think
there's only two
mandatory columns but I can't seem to
scroll up but that's all right
insert into
business licenses
ID and license
ID values and we'll just call this demo
and 9876
okay so we inserted one row let's double
check we're on Aurora here
yes see the RDS users we're on Aurora
and again if we check now against Omni
yes you see we're up to 10 ends with 89.
so the rule came across so that's all
good so I just showed that it's very
easy to copy your data in near real time
from Aurora to Omni
but why would we want to do that well we
might want to test some of the new
features right so let's say I have this
query that I mentioned I want to know
what business is opened in my ZIP code
in the last 90 days and
oops
okay so there's this query and I just
want to do an explain on that to see
what the performance is so first let's
be let me connect to Aurora
and
make a Baseline
displaying query
okay so that told me down the very
bottom here that the execution time was
266 milliseconds that's pretty quick but
this is just for demo purposes maybe in
your real environment it's an ordered or
two orders or three orders of magnitude
more
and let's run it a couple times right
just so that we can warm up caches and
stuff this time a little higher 353 292
266. so we get an idea it's close to 300
or the high 200s so the first thing I
want to do is try the same test against
Omni so let's collect connect to
localhost
and let's do explain all right so we got
something pretty similar well we expect
it to be kind of similar because the
size and shape of my Aurora and my ec2
are the same size but there's probably
other differences but we're getting in
the same kind of ballpark we're on the
300 milliseconds so the last thing I
might want to do is enable the columnar
engine and see what kind of difference
that makes
so to do that I just have a add CE
script and it only takes 10 seconds here
it's going to show you what I did all I
did is I said I want to mark this table
to load it into columnar memory as well
I said 10 seconds there we go 10 seconds
almost 11. and now let's just rerun the
query and see what the difference is
all right seven right so you see I
dropped from 300 milliseconds to seven
milliseconds let's do it a couple times
just to make sure it's consistent you
see 6.8 6.9 6.7 so
end result there is sure there's lots of
different ways you can tune a query you
could add indexes you could restructure
it but if you have a package staff maybe
you can't do all of those things so I
just wanted to experiment here and show
that by just enabling the columnar
engine and loading this one table into
columnar memory and not doing anything
else I seem to have gotten about a 40
times increase in performance
so there you go the demo was all worked
even though I was almost sabotaged
[Applause]
if we go back to the slides please
yeah and a couple key points about the
demo
um Simon didn't even you know do it
efficiently because he loaded the entire
table all the columns into the columnar
engine he only really needed the columns
that were in his query to speed up the
query so he could have gotten you know
more precise but really the right way to
do this at scale is to turn on the
automatic management of the data driven
by ml looking at your query patterns
look at your data it will automatically
put the right Columns of memory for you
so come back next year and the demo will
be improved right yeah well yeah so so
you know there's there's more to it and
and he could have turned all that on it
just takes a little while for that
engine to learn your query patterns and
then start loading data so to do a demo
we usually have to force the data in
early
um let's move some slides okay so I want
to talk a little bit about Sport and
partners I mentioned earlier that we are
going to provide full support once we're
GA but to go from Tech preview to public
preview what we've also done is in
addition to continuing to support
um Ali DB Omni on our Discord server
which a lot of that is Gabe and his team
answering your questions on the hashtag
Cloud databases channel in Discord we
also will respond to support cases so if
you have a support account you file a
support case about a question or issue
with LGB Omni we'll do a best effort you
know response we're not following
support slos yet because it's public
preview it's not a supportive product
but we will do our best effort to start
helping customers from support
and the partners we have you know in
addition to pythian and they're a great
partner we've got a whole bunch of
launch Partners lodb uh Omni public
preview launch Partners who have ramped
up on how to help customers with ldb
Omni how to help you with pocs and and
testing and moving workloads
um you know and pythians of course right
there on the slide but there's you know
there's there's a big world out there
and there's a lot of Partners a lot of
customers need help
um so I just want to you know say hey
these these These are the partners who
are ready when you have questions about
what what you can do with how to be Omni
and then other things we've added we've
added postgres 15.2 when we launched the
tech preview March it was still 14.4 we
moved it to 15.2 and when we go ga we
will just support 15.2 we're not going
to support the old uh postgres 14
version at all
um this matters to some people who pay
close attention to what the postgres
community adds in the new major version
so from 14 to 15 they've added a bunch
of new cool stuff that's all available
in Omni since it is 100 postgres
compatible
and then I mentioned this earlier we
just yesterday morning we published a
set of detailed technical guides on how
to implement various data protection
scenarios how to do backups how to do
turn on replication like you saw Simon
do but trying to replica replication for
more complex use cases like ha and
failover and Dr
so there's a bunch of detail guides
which once we go ga we will provide full
support for those guides as well those
guys do depend on open source tools and
features we'll be fully supporting uh
any any problems you might run into with
all of those capabilities
and then we've also added a support for
our enhanced PG vector and integration
with vertex AI and you probably have
heard a lot about these especially if
you saw the allodb session yesterday or
Andy gutman's Spotlight session
um these are analog to be Omni and in of
course an LGB Cloud as well so you can
build gen iops right now on Ali to be
Omni on your laptop
um if it's connected to the cloud you
can use vertex AI as well but you can
use PG Vector even on your laptop
disconnected
and one thing that isn't on the slide we
also just yesterday launched a separate
Tech preview so it's an earlier Stage
Preview of valid to be Omni with local
embedded models so it's kind of like
working with vertex AI but you don't
need to call vertex AI there's a couple
bottles we've embedded in the local
download of omni so you can actually
test those capabilities without even
being connected to the cloud
and like I said we're not going to talk
much about pricing other than we're
sticking to what we committed to back in
March and make a simple transparent
affordable and we will continue to have
a free Developer Edition
so that is available now and it will
continue to be available when we go ga
now I'm going to hand it back off to
Simon yeah and lastly if you're just
starting out and your organization is
interested in getting going with
postgres in Google Cloud we offer a free
no cost to you one day workshop where
somebody like myself can work with your
technical teams either remotely or on
site to go through your migration
journey to really it's kind of the
opposite of here we're all coming to San
Francisco and getting sessions this is
the opposite where all the sessions come
to you including a lot of Hands-On labs
and actual Hands-On keyboard stuff and
collaborating and brainstorming on
migration paths so if that's of interest
to you and you're just starting your
journey reach out to us and we could
maybe arrange to do a free Workshop
and to that end like the first thing
that we want you to do is go try it grab
it it's easy to use just go to that
quick start page get started download it
and play around with it during this
public preview right now before we're
talking about pricing it's free to use
so get it play with it kick the tires
give us feedback and let us know what
you like what you don't like so we can
make improvements as we go the last bit
before they kick us out uh please do do
the feedback on the session in the app
go through let us know what you liked
what you didn't like if you want better
sessions the next year this is the way
to get them
and with that thank you very much for
coming for our session we are out of
time but we'll we'll meet you outside to
chat if you want
foreign